all
right uh let's just work with
katata so he's going to grab cool all
right and do it again watch his grip
cool and one more
time cool all right uh let's do this
side now so you can see on the back side
cool a little
slower slow cool and again
all
right A lot of times what we do
is uh we might recognize his spinal
displacement so you're going to see I
won't ground it this time as he goes you
could see it in the tilt of his torso
okay do it one more time I won't ground
it so you see the effect on me
okay um and so we P we think he's going
this way and so as long as
I um have my motion going in a in a
harmonious Direction with that we think
we have not
contested okay but if we just slow
motion uh pretend my arm is
there okay and if you pay attention the
fingers are going the other way so yes
his spine he's doing spinal displacement
but the fingers are going back the other
way do you see that so if I actually go
this way I'm actually contesting the
fingers
okay your choreograph ID they were going
to fly that way anyway so you don't
really feel it but your scaredy cat ukes
or the ukes who are just grounding
you'll feel the fingers okay and and
you'll feel the Yong of the fingers
because you're yanging on the fingers
okay um that is another reason why the
hand workk that we use isn't for example
like this
one here remember remember that EO
because you're pulling against the
fingers that's a y Yong Clash even
though it's not a push push it's a pull
p pull
okay a lot of people that do that
version like to have that
pull that they're looking for that it's
the same o uh you know ego tripartite
mind will to power overpowering okay but
it's not iido it's this young young
Clash okay but in our handworth you'll
see that the tabaki that we use it's
going to reconcile the fingerpull as as
it reconciles the spinal displacement so
for example in
Gon Do you see his fingers are going
this way and I'm turning within his
fingers and as I do gon you see that my
hand can come back towards me without
losing the elbow angle meaning I don't
have to go like this do you see so in my
gon
I don't pull on the fingers I'm inside
his grip got it and so the the Eco that
we're doing is I go this way do you see
and then around and I'm working inside
the fingers on the inward
fire
so I never feel his fingers do that
again remember his fingers are doing
that I don't I go around his fingers
around his fingers inside his
palm okay some of the stuff we were
doing like if I if I come here and I go
to Cheon remember his fingers are still
going that way right and go to chew on I
don't feel his fingers till the grip
weakens and then I'm
[Music]
out so again and in fingers are still
curling that way then I'm inside his
grip not inside his
fingers till they
weaken meaning they become Yin and I can
push through
them same thing I go to
jodon I'm
inside I'm not going to pull on his
fingers his fingers are going going that
way not going to pull on his finger and
try to get up as I'm going through I'm
I'm in
here in here never feeling his
g bo
pop inside his STP inside his grip
inside no don't pull push inside his
and there it
[Music]
is inside the grip inside the grip
inside the grip never against the
fingers okay uh so that will be our
first progression those are the three
techniques we did in the last video on
tesak okay and you take that first one
into EO we went to Koko we'll take it
into EO okay and then you had ID nag in
Chan and then we had hij at
J TR so as I said you have to you you
only have your inward spiral and you and
then it's inverse reverse you have your
outward spiral that's all you have okay
there's no this movement this movement
is not in
iido so I can't go from get
on and then go to jodon you see that
I know you think you can but look his
fingers are going down do you see that
so you can't come up you're going to do
this and now you're losing connection
there do you see and he has to
artificially do it got it so
instead
one two and I turn it turn it inside
turn turn inside you see and I keep
turning it I'm I'm
now this way going that way going not
here rip I'm going to hold his hand
still you guys can come around the
camera didn't come around okay I'm not
going to open his
fingers okay I'm going to turn his hand
you see and his fingers aren't
challenged and I'm moving his
palm then the throw came
up
VI same thing
on you go I want to do jodon so I am
going to just cut here do you see no
don't
boom near inside now now
look over here look at how big that is
you see and I just tap and I move
outside that pull I
made I know it
looks like you could just go here like
this but I have to pry it I have to do
one more
turn now I can come out like just slips
out you cannot go from gon to jodon okay
just like you can't go straight to
jodan you can't you can't go like this
cuz I don't have a center you see that
you just
here okay then if he's pushing at
me and I try to go
up that's not going to work it works
because he does his little acrobatics to
Stay With Me do you
see that's though there's no
energetics to it there's no lower tondon
field there's no sensation of the god
mind you just have this little trophy in
this fake ass world of Kon waza okay try
it again all right progression two when
when I am inside his fingers
and not contesting the backward pulling
of
them what's moving him it's the adhesion
on his
palm that's what's moving
him okay that's what's moving
him instead of where I use the pull and
I pull against it
you
understand I
adhere keep your fingers completely open
okay I
adhere that's what I'm
doing
okay so we'll
do those three techniques again but he
he has to
open
okay and I stick to him and I do this
same
movement so again you can I'll try to
play with the
iy so that you see my skin
move okay which is telling you there's
friction there okay so just
relax okay so stay still stay still I'll
do it do you see see my skin
okay there's friction there
versus okay so I keep that
adhesion I work the
Palm I keep
it work
get
technique then you saw me slip it just
like in the ground fighting I don't want
the adhesion
anymore so I have to relax
my arm right here there's lots of
friction I'm he has his fingers right
and I'll keep the friction going but I
want it to slip now you see I relax the
arm I change the Y output
value if we doing this the other
techniques right should you're just
moving that Palm there it
is
keep it open
right C keep it open I move it
inside you're going to feel
it hold the last technique keep it open
I'll make contact with you boom boom
boom okay let's try so inside his grab
that's what I'm doing every time so
inside is grab you're not relying on the
pulling of the fingers to give you your
leverage points so inside your grab
you're doing the same thing okay and you
have to not rely on the fingers and then
try to overpower the finger pull okay
um in that last drill it looks like he's
like pushing on me but I just had his
hand there it's
loose okay he's not pushing on me I'm
just matching it okay it's not that he
pushes on me so the same thing here it's
not that he's pushing on me and I'm just
getting out of the way I'm stuck on the
inside I move him okay
I've demonstrated several times like um
he tries to pull back I'll stick to him
you could open it's sticky it's stickier
you
see or even in this last technique as as
we did the uh e
Minag you watch his try to get this hand
okay and you see that I'm pulling the
skin come
back pulling the skin his skin but I'm
not grabbing it I'm just pulling it and
he tries to pull away more it get there
more skin right there's more friction
there that's why you can do the
throw
this without having to hook anything
okay so don't get
confused now that said
when you
are a skilled UK so if I had a crappy UK
I'm going to be doing that all the time
the net I'm going to stick to the inside
of their Palm I'm going to reconcile the
finger pull what makes the crappy
UK is once you start
moving they will do stuff like that
they'll use the finger pull you guys so
so for example I going to finally
justplay whoa and they grab like scared
people on Rails that are they're going
to fall and they hold on to the rail
okay so if
I if he I feel him doing that I just
turn do you see inside the fingers and I
don't feel the bite and he came anyways
do you
see
okay so baduk
you you would do what we do and you
don't feel the
fingers okay you reconcile the
finger but you're a
good so as a good you don't use the
fingers you use the
adhesion
so again you watch his
skin that's what I
want with my palm so that with my
adhesion I can move his Center I don't
move his Center in spinal displacement
by grabbing here you see it just here
boom
stick though my fingers are closed
they're not using to keep my connection
I don't use this to keep my connection
on the palm the Palm is the same I
adhesion that he's using okay so I'm
here
not go and I start
pulling if you if you pay
attention there's my little space
there you see and I don't want the space
he goes but I don't keep no face by
grabbing harder I keep the adhesion and
I move with the
[Music]
adhesion so if we're
standing same don't move the adhesion is
the connection do you
see we does a technique I can keep my
hands open open and move with
him and more
importantly if he's skilled I'm letting
him move me if he's
unskilled I'm generating the energetics
I don't need him to
okay all right so in these
drills you will keep your your hands
open okay your hands are open and you
have the adhesion before my hand was
open and he had the adhesion now I have
the adhesion and I keep
it okay
try
[Music]
come
so that would be I'm a good UK and my
Naga is not skilled okay if I'm a good
net
um I will do the adhesion in the Palm
they're going to keep trying to get out
of it okay doesn't change what I'm going
to do
okay if I am a skilled nag and a skilled
UK uh I'm going to be using that
adhesion to its fullest and he will
never break it like the bad UK he just
keeps it he allows it to be there he
knows what it feels like or she knows
what it feels like and it's fine to them
okay um a lot of people will
want to ask Marshall questions again let
it go you asking Marshall questions
because you're trying to fight with
energetic
rituals you need to fix your first
this this is not a marshal situation and
know in Marshal situations I am not
unarmed and I do not let people touch me
for
free so so there's no wrist grab and
there's no arm wrestling it's
but in terms of
energetics it is way more
valuable than trying to armar somebody
that's ridiculous you're you're you're
missing the
miracle for a piece of
and really that's your bigger
problem that you confuse the miraculous
with that's where all your
attention should go what why do I have
this confusion problem
okay once you understand the
energetics and you can actually develop
I and
cou then your
Marshall
applications which require an expansion
of the curriculum then those two become
viable and they become iido but they're
not grab my wrist let me do a Kon waza
that's just ridiculous
okay